Here's a well-thrown disk. But have you ever
thrown one badly, so that as it spins, there's
a wobble? This wobble rotates with a different
frequency than the disk itself spins.
In this video, we're going to describe mathematically
the motion of all of the points on this badly
thrown disk.
This video is part of the Linearity Video
Series. Many complex systems are modeled or
approximated linearly because of the mathematical
advantages.
Hi, my name is Dan Frey, and I am a professor
of Engineering Systems and Mechanical Engineering
at MIT. And I use rigid body kinematics myself
when designing radio--controlled aircraft.
Before watching this video, you should be
familiar with eigenvalues and eigenvectors,
the standard basis, e1, e2, e3 of R3, and
orthogonal matrices.
After watching this video, you will be able
to: identify rotation matrices; decompose
the motion of the badly thrown disk into translational
and rotational components; and write the rotational
motion of the disk as a product of rotation
matrices.
Our goal is to describe the motion of the
disk. The disk is a rigid body; it doesn't
stretch, bend, or deform in any way when it
is thrown.
In this video, we're not interested in why
the disk moves the way it does—that is,
we're not trying to describe torques and forces
that govern the motion. We simply want to
describe the motion mathematically. This is
a job for rigid body kinematics. We're going
to describe the motion by decomposing it into
translational and rotational components.
We'll start with the mathematics of rotation
matrices.
This will allow us to build up to a description
of the wobbly disk.
Finally, we'll complete the description of
the wobbly disk by adding in the translational
component.
Let's start with some linear algebra.
A rotation is a mapping that takes any vector
in R3 to some other vector in R3 via rotation
about some axis by some angle.
Rotations don't change the length of a vector.
So, if you scale a vector and then rotate
it, you get the same thing as if you first
rotate it, and then scale the vector.
Also, if you take two vectors, sum them and
then rotate the sum, this is equal to vector
you would get if you first rotate both vectors
and then add them.
These two properties together mean that Rotations
act linearly on vectors.
And by definition, linear operations can be
represented by matrices.
But what does a rotation matrix look like?
We can learn a lot about a matrix by examining
its eigenvalues and eigenvectors. Recall that
a vector v is an eigenvector of a matrix if
it is sent to a scalar multiple of itself
when acted upon by the matrix.
That scalar is the eigenvalue.
Consider a rotation of 60 degrees about the
axis defined by the vector e1+e2. Pause the
video here and determine one eigenvalue and
eigenvector. By the definition of an eigenvector,
the vector e1+e2, which points along the axis
of rotation, is an eigenvector with eigenvalue
one. This is because this vector is UNCHANGED
by the rotation matrix.
Suppose you have a rotation matrix such that
e1 and e2 are both eigenvectors with eigenvalue
1.
What would this mean about the rotation? Pause
the video and think about this. The entire
xy-plane will be unchanged by this rotation.
This is only possible if the matrix is the
identity matrix! This is the null rotation...
nothing happens! What are the eigenvalues
and eigenvectors of a 180-degree rotation
about the z-axis?
This rotation matrix has one eigenvalue of
1, corresponding to the vector e3, which points
along the axis of rotation.
But it has more eigenvectors: any vector in
the xy-plane is sent to its negative by the
rotation, so any vector in the xy-plane is
an eigenvector with eigenvalue -1.
Now let's consider a rotation by some angle
theta (that is not an integer multiple of
pi) clockwise about the z-axis.
Write a matrix that represents such a rotation.
Compute the eigenvalues of this matrix, and
use the definition of an eigenvector to explain
why this makes sense.
You should have found 1 real eigenvalue equal
to 1, and two complex conjugate eigenvalues.
The real eigenvalue corresponds to the eigenvector
e3, which is sent to itself by the rotation,
hence the eigenvalue of 1.
The fact that the other two eigenvalues are
complex means that no other vector is sent
to a REAL scalar multiple of itself.
This makes sense geometrically because NO
other vector points in the same direction
it started in after being rotated. Now, how
do we describe any general rotation about
an arbitrary axis?
Well, a matrix is completely defined by how
it acts on basis vectors.
Since a rotation doesn't change the lengths
of vectors or the angles BETWEEN two vectors,
a rotated basis will also be a basis for R3!
This tells us that any rotation matrix can
be described as an orthonormal matrix.
The columns are the vectors each standard
basis vector is sent to.
Is it true that ALL orthonormal matrices rotate
vectors? Pause the video. Nope, here's an
orthonormal matrix that's not a rotation;
it's a reflection.
The rule is that only an orthonormal matrix
whose determinant is positive 1 is a rotation.
But let's get back to thinking about rigid
body KINEMATICS. Remember, we want to describe
the motion of the disk. We've talked about
rotation matrices, but we've left out a very
important component: time!
How will we describe time dependent rotation?
That's right, time dependent matrices.
Let's start by modeling a simple motion: the
rotation of a disk as it spins clockwise about
the positive z-axis.
We know how to write a matrix that describes
rotation by an angle theta about the z-axis.
How would you make this rotation time dependent?
Pause the video and discuss.
The obvious choice here is to simply make
theta a function of time! But how does it
depend on time?
To write an explicit function, we need to
know the rate, omega, at which the disk is
rotating.
Assume the disk spins with constant angular
velocity.
We can easily calculate omega by counting
the revolutions per second.
And there's our matrix for a spinning—but
not wobbling—disk.
Now let's try a slightly more difficult example.
Let's describe the motion of this wobbly,
spinning disk as it rotates on this stick.
The disk is itself rotating clockwise about
its center of mass when viewed from the positive
z-axis. As before, we can find the rotation
rate, omega-D, of a marked point by counting
the revolutions per second. Assume omega_D
is constant. Now, observe the slight tilt
of the disk off of horizontal.
This tilt is created by a rotation about a
tilt axis.
The tilt axis is the vector in the xy-plane
about which the disk is rotated by some small
angle theta, creating the tilt. The wobble
is created because the tilt axis is rotating
clockwise about the positive z-axis.
We can visualize this by observing that the
normal vector to the disk rotates in a cone
shape about the z-axis. By tracking the normal
vector's revolutions per second, we can find
the rotation rate of the wobble, omega-W,
of the normal vector. This is also the rotation
rate for tilt axis. We assume omega_W is constant.
Notice that omega-D and omega-W are different
rotation rates.
For simplicity, we assume that the marked
point begins along the x-axis; and the initial
tilt axis aligns with the x-axis, with the
tilt angle theta.
Let's start by creating a sequence of rotations
that rotates the marked point to the angle
omega_D times t and the tilt axis to the angle
omega_W times t for any time t.
To describe this motion, we are going to decompose
the behavior into a sequence of rotations
about e1, e2, and e3, which have the benefit
of being easy to describe mathematically.
I want to start by eliminating the tilt of
the disk, so we can imagine it spinning parallel
to the ground.
What is the matrix that undoes the tilt of
theta degrees about the x-axis? Pause and
write down a matrix. We rotate by an angle
negative theta about the positive x-axis,
which is represented by this matrix.
Now, I rotate the marked point clockwise about
the z-axis by the angle (omega_D minus omega_W)
times t.
This matrix describes the angle difference
traveled by the marked point relative to the
position of the tilt axis. Now, we need to
make sure that we tilt the disk again so that
we can describe the wobble.
Since we assume the tilt axis begins along
the x-axis, we rotate the disk back to the
initial tilted position by theta degrees.
This counterclockwise, time-independent rotation
about the x-axis is represented by this matrix.
Finally we must describe the wobble, created
by the rotation of the tilt axis. The tilt
axis is rotating clockwise about the positive
z-axis with rotation rate omega-W, so at time
t, it has rotated by omega_W t degrees, which
is what this matrix does.
How will we combine these matrices to describe
the motion of the marked point?
Pause and discuss.
We multiply the matrices together. The order
we apply each matrix matters. We must perform
the rotations in the same order we decomposed
the motion, because matrices do not multiply
commutatively.
Let's understand geometrically why this worked.
The angle of the marker is changed in two
steps of this process, first a rotation by
angle omega-D minus omega-W times t, and then
by an angle omega_W times t.
In the end, it ends up exactly where it should,
at omega-D times t. Only the final matrix
affects the tilt axis, rotating it by the
angle omega-W times t.
Because the disk is a rigid object, by describing
the position of the marked point and the tilt
axis for all times with matrices, we've actually
described the position of every point on the
disk.
We can find the location of any point at time
t by applying this matrix operation to any
vector on the initial disk. Now, let's go
back to the badly thrown disk.
We can apply the rotational transformation
directly to our thrown disk.
The only changes might be to the rotation
rates and the initial position. You can think
about how we might change the formula. We'll
ignore that. So all that is left to consider
is the translation.
If you throw a disk and watch it from the
side, we can ignore the rotations and focus
on the translation of the center point of
the disk. For the small time interval that
we are interested in describing, the disk
moves in a straight, horizontal path. So this
vector equation approximates the translation.
Because the disk is a rigid object, we get
the full description of the motion by simply
adding in the translation.
To the rotation of the wobbly disk to obtain
the following equation of motion for any point
on the disk.
If you thought this problem was cool, you're
not the only one. Richard Feynman studied
the kinematics AND the dynamics of the wobbly
disk. He was able to show that the rotation
rate of the special marked point, omega-D,
was exactly twice the rotation rate, omega-W,
of the tilt axis. This realization ultimately
led to insights into the behavior of electrons.
In this video, we saw that rotation matrices
are orthogonal matrices with determinant equal
to positive 1.
The kinematics of rigid bodies involves breaking
a problem into translation and rotation.
The rotations may be decomposed into several
time dependent rotation matrices that are
multiplied together.
The matrix product added to the translation
describes the location at any time of all
points on the rigid body.
I hope you'll try to describe the motions
of various rotating objects that you encounter.
Have fun, and good luck!